I've been overly Fair because I've been
through five pandemics with him right he
was my he was really my man during HIV
MERS SARS one H1N1 h1n was a terrible
pandemic you don't even know what
happened that's what I kept saying that
was bad and you're worrying about this
one like why didn't we have a moderate
reaction to that one at least why this
reaction anyway but uh so I figured he
had been adulterated by the every would
everyone get adulterated with which is
the tribalism of our time and I thought
he would revert to the mean I thought
his his overall function has always been
like his judgment has been awesome and I
would see I assume I still to this day
believe we'll see a reversion to the
mean in terms of him looking okay
however he finally did something that
upset me
all right I'm in studio with a live a
real live human being according to the
paperwork Dr Drew Pinsky it is good to
see you my friend good to see you and I
to be fair I insisted on this I did you
were like no we'll do it by Zoom I'm
like no I don't want to do if I was
doing anymore I'm tired of this I've
seen this great Studio I want to be in
it with you I want to see you it's good
to see you we are less than six feet
apart so we're risking everything right
now I'm as immune as I can possibly be
you've had covered like 18 times that
covet I've had the antibiotics I've had
the uh injection I've had the vaccine
I'm good and and I do something that no
one does I'm following a very
sophisticated antibody screen with my
neutralizing antibodies and my B cell
function so I can tell you categorically
if I get covet it'd be reportable do you
feel like your life's work has led to
this moment no I don't I never expected
any of this time nor do I really welcome
it to be fear but uh but I I will you
know I took the Johnson Johnson vaccine
myself and I had a nasty reaction to it
really bad I woke up with a sudden black
eye this is called a raccoon's eye which
is the presenting symptom of transverse
sinus thrombosis which is the dreaded
complication of the Johnson Johnson I'm
looking in the mirror going oh God damn
it am I going to have a transverse size
thrombosis and nothing so and nothing
did you choose the Johnson Johnson I did
I did I I sort of picked it earlier for
two reasons one I I react horribly to
viruses horribly to vaccines so I kind
of just wanted one vaccine silly me now
I need another but I I was hoping just
to get by with one also I like the idea
of a sort of an old-fashioned platform
and nothing against modern I might even
take the moderna now or the our mRNA
vaccines but I just thought I react to
everything better I use some
old-fashioned so before we get to the
book which I'm holding in my hand so
I'll put it down for a moment let's just
do the the coveted stuff
to the side you've got antibodies you
did Johnson and Johnson you don't have a
problem with mRNA is there anything that
people should know about the MRNA is you
know we're hearing so much conflicting
stuff and I had Dr Brian Keating on my
show last night last week talking about
that people just don't trust experts
anymore and in many cases it's the
expert's fault right so particularly the
cdc's fault I mean and the government
anybody associated with public health or
CDC has created vaccine hesitancy
they've created it they've done
everything wrong they should have been
from the beginning wide open here's our
thinking here's our concerns here's the
debate we have Behind Closed here all
that is how you get people who are
resistant to loosen up and come on board
you treat them like intelligent people
who need to be reasoned with and you
give them all the information you don't
say you can't handle the truth you can't
handle the truth I don't I'd become
resistant when what's bizarre to me is
we we learned how to do this during the
HIV epidemic I don't know if I ever told
you this I got involved in radio because
in 1983 one Anthony fauci who was my
hero at the time was telling us young
Physicians that we had to get out there
and educate and change Behavior because
we did we couldn't get people to stop
having sex and passing this virus and I
thought oh I took it very seriously and
we learned across that that pandemic
with a 100 fatality rate it was the
darkest The Darkest Hours we learned
that the way you change behaviors is
with narratives and information and
showing the consequences of people's
people's choices a little humor a little
music that's how you change Behavior not
me in a box pointing my finger at
somebody the opposite right so I've
heard you talk about your experience
with fauci then and and you've been I
think very fair to fauci I would say
almost overly Fair like I mean overly
Fair because yeah I've been through five
pandemics with him right he was my he
was really my man during HIV MERS SARS
one H1N1 h1n was a terrible pandemic you
don't even know what happened that's
what I kept saying I was like that was
bad and you're worrying about this one
like why didn't we have a moderate
reaction to that one at least why this
reaction anyway but uh so I figured he
had been adulterated by the every would
everyone get adulterated with which is
the tribalism of our time and I thought
he would revert to the mean I thought
his his overall function has always been
like his judgment has been awesome and I
would see I assume I still to this day
believe we'll see a reversion to the
mean in terms of him looking okay
however he finally did something that
upset me
which was I don't know if you remember
in front of Congress multiple times
whenever they would ask him about the
gain of function or funding they've
covered it he would just be like I'm
confused what are you talking about
nothing like two days ago he goes well
you know we did fund change viral
function but we did not this but we were
changing viruses right that was the word
why did you tell us that's what we were
that's how you create vaccine hesitancy
now it's like okay I can't trust you you
knew we were asking answer the damn
question be open about this trust the
American people to be able to digest
what you're telling them and give them a
recommendation and then move on so do
you think in essence he lied under oath
to rent I don't really have an opinion
about that so much because change of
seems to be the word that he's you can't
do that right now you've got to be open
and honest you cannot obfuscate this is
dissembling you cannot whether it's you
know lying or you know worthy of sort of
further investigation I have no opinion
it's dissembling it's obfuscating you
can't be that way now that's how you
create vaccine hesitancy I've gotten to
the point now where I'm telling people
your problem I've talked to lots of
vaccine hesitant people your problem is
you don't know who to trust so here's
what I want you to do I want you to find
if it's for the kids find a pediatrician
for its you find an attorneys that you
trust and you sit down with that person
and you too make that medical decision
the way we're supposed to make all
[ __ ] medical decisions the fact that
anybody has an opinion about what a
doctor does with his patients is
offensive and disgusting the fact that
anybody has opinion about what Joe Rogan
doctor does with him that's disgusting
now other Physicians can have opinions
about it and we can discuss it
professionally but for people in the
world to interfere with that
relationship that is disgusting and why
people aren't more upset about the
adulteration of the relationship between
doctors and patients I I'm
I know you pretty well off camera too
I'm pretty sure I've never heard Dr Drew
or my friend say say I'm upset so so I
get it so not that I don't say it
so you you put a pretty party on here
I've had my best behavior I do all right
you know uh but so to that end I mean I
assume I've heard you talk about a
little bit are you a hundred percent
against mandates as a as a general rule
foreign
you just never do that so am I against
mandates generally yes absolutely I'm
against the idea that this now I
understand that we need to do things to
urge populations to do certain things I
don't see where it's the look I was in
even in France recently it's very I've
only been to France once it was in 1997.
I suggest you go back there now because
it's very interesting what's happening
there what's happening there they have
same mandates we have essentially they
apply it very differently when you go to
the Louvre you can show your EU pass or
go over there and get a test if you'd
like whatever you want and or you can
show us your antibodies from your
natural immunity
rational that's not a man there's a
mandate but a rational application of a
mandate and the really interesting thing
is the youth are fighting like crazy so
18 to 28 year olds are in the streets by
the thousands yeah you don't see that on
CNN Vive La liberte is their call this
is I've spoke my French is pretty good I
spoke to a lot of them because I was
intrigued I'm like young people not
asking for more mask wearing I might
understand they were Furious and their
position was look you've educated us
rightly that this thing is not a major
risk to us now you're mandating us put
something in our bodies we may choose to
do it and you can help us make that
decision if you think it's so mandating
it no and it's it's it's Echoes of 1790.
I'm telling you they will they bring up
the same language as 1790 they raise
their fists and they've got a history of
the heading over there well I don't
think this is that kind of mob action
yeah but that's going on here you know
it's called cancel culture if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check check out our
politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell